depuis près d'un an madagascar connaît
une crise alimentaire inédites qu'on
impute en partie aux copies de 10,9 et
en partie une sécheresse probablement
liés au dérèglement climatique selon
l'organisation des nations unies ce sont
plus d'un millions de malgaches qui sont
en insécurité alimentaire sévère et
comme si cela ne suffisait pas deux
cyclones tropicaux se sont ensuite
abattus sur le pays rend dans une
situation déjà précaire encore plus
catastrophique comme vous le savez sans
doute les activités humaines sont en
train de dangereusement déstabiliser
l'environnement or il ne s'agit là
probablement que d'un début des millions
de vies humaines présentes et futures
voire plus encore risque d'être menacé
chaque année à cause des conséquences de
l'activité économique humaine et de
façon terriblement injuste les victimes
seront plus probablement des populations
défavorisées qui bien souvent sont aussi
celles qui ne sont pas le plus
responsable du dérèglement climatique
pour éviter une amplification drastique
de la crise humanitaire actuelle et les
risques de conflits armés qui
l'accompagnent voir de tensions
géopolitiques voire de guerre mondiale
il semble urgent de réduire
drastiquement notre empreinte
environnementale en particulier nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre qui
dérègle temps le climat mais comment
obtenir une telle réduction drastique
comment amener des populations entières
à polluer beaucoup moins je vous
recommande à ce sujet cette excellente
vidéo de paloma moritz il ya beaucoup de
choses que vous pouvez faire en
participant notamment à la guerre de
l'information
vous l'aurez compris il y a un immense
enjeu autour de la formation en france
le dérèglement climatique est considéré
comme un enjeu capital par 94% des
citoyens mais si de plus en plus de
personnes sont conscientes du défi
climatique très peu ont réellement
compris le degré d'urgence dans lequel
nous sommes autre action donc la
bataille de l'information on sous estime
souvent son pouvoir en tant qu'individu
pour cela mais si à chaque fois que vous
lisez un article regardez une vidéo un
documentaire qui vous a permis de mieux
comprendre le problème vous le partager
avec votre entourage je vous assure
beaucoup de choses changeront aussi et
on vous le répète souvent chez blast il
est primordial de soutenir et mettre en
avant tous les médias indépendants qui
accorde la place qu'elle mérite à
l'urgence écologique dans leur ligne
éditoriale des médias qui montrent que
ce sujet n'est pas une rubrique parmi
d'autres mais le prisme à travers lequel
tous les sujets doivent être analysées
et repensé vous pouvez donc partager les
contenus qui parle d'écologie au max hi
mom les laïcs et les commenter pour
qu'elle se fasse une place dans la
guerre des algorithmes soutenir les
médias qui en parlent mais aussi
interpeller ceux qui ne le font pas en
écrivant aux journalistes aux rédactions
en appelant les standards pour poser des
questions sur ces sujets ce qui a
d'ailleurs beaucoup a été fait pendant
la présidentielle l'objectif est d'
exiger un traitement ambitieux des
enjeux à la fois au niveau quantitatif
et qualitatif
enfin vous pouvez aussi signalé au csa
les propos climato sceptiques ou
dangereux encore tenus sur certains
plateaux l'urgence écologique devrait
être sur toutes les chaînes
d'information donc tous les débats
politiques et plus vous serez nombreux à
le réclamer plus ce sera le cas à ce
sujet il ya également une bataille des
imaginaires à mener pour montrer ce à
quoi pourrait ressembler un monde où
france dans laquelle nous aurons réussi
à faire face aux défis écologiques à
nous adapter montré que cet avenir peut
être désirable souhaitable qu'une autre
société est possible si vous êtes un
artiste vous pouvez contribuer à faire
émerger ce nouveau récit et si vous
aimez le cinéma la littérature partager
ce qui existe déjà je vous encourage
ainsi à identifier les vidéos d'utilité
publique sur tournesol pour faciliter la
découverte et l'amplification de ces
vidéos néanmoins aujourd'hui j'aimerais
parler d'une autre mesure beaucoup trop
absent du discours écologiste à mon goût
et qui est pourtant au coeur de la
société de consommation qui causent
dérèglement climatique à savoir la
publicité la publicité qui est mentionné
16 fois dans le sixième rapport du
groupe iii du giec qui fait presque 3000
pages 16 mentions sur 3000 pages c'est
quand même pas beaucoup surtout que sa
cible rarement la publicité ciblée de
produits polluants après tout comment
parle des associations comme résistant à
l'agression publicitaire ou casseurs de
pub le marché de publicité est
précisément celui qui pousse des
milliards d'humains à la consommation
voire à la surconsommation et a négligé
l'empreinte sociale et environnementale
de cette consommation il me semble plus
urgent que jamais de mettre fin à ce
carnage et pour cela j'aimerais vous
parler d'une proposition concrète et
très simple un euro de publicité égale
dix autos taxes autrement dit une taxe à
1000% sur la publicité au moins pour
ceux qui passent par les services de
géant de la terre avec réduction
potentielle pour les publicités
d'intérêt public comme l'appelle à
l'utilisation du vélo l'alimentation
plus durable ou une invitation à mieux
s'informer sur les enjeux
civilisationnels je vous propose
d'abréger cette proposition en hashtag
taxons la pub et à utiliser massivement
ce reichstag sur les réseaux sociaux
le problème de la publicité transforme
d'ailleurs largement le problème
environnemental
trop souvent la publicité encourage des
consommations en fait dangereuse pour
les consommateurs voire pour leurs
proches voire pour des populations
entières d'humains qui ne profitent pas
directement de la publicité je vous
propose cinq catégories de conséquences
désastreuses de la publicité 1 les
publicités les plus clairement
dérangeante sont certainement les
arnaques or il est en fait extrêmement
fréquent que des publicités promeuvent
de la voyance des pseudos médecine ou
d'obscurs montage financier par exemple
autour de cryptome n'est ou de nfc par
exemple il ya quelques mois technology
review révéler l'abondance de mes
informations dans les publicités
facebook sur les traitements contre le
cancer et de façon calais blement
perturbante jusqu'en 2020 facebook
permettait aux annonceurs de cibler des
publics particulièrement vulnérables à
ces arnaques comme les adeptes de pseudo
science or si depuis cette catégorie
informellement disparu nul doute que les
algorithmes de ciblage publicitaire
técher du web ont appris d'eux mêmes à
bombarder sans intervention humaine des
publics vulnérables à des arnaques
dangereuse mais surtout dans le cas des
publicités en ligne il faut absolument
garder en tête que la quantité de telles
publicités mensongères et dangereuse est
monumentale si bien que des algorithmes
sont indispensables pour les analyser et
les modérés ainsi dès 2016 google
annonce est retiré chaque année des
dizaines de millions de publicités pour
des pseudos médecine dangereuses ou pour
des jeux d'argent illégaux et près de
100 millions de publicités trompeuses en
2020 l'entreprise annonçait ainsi retiré
des milliards de mauvaise publicité par
an soit 5000 publicité par minute 5000
mauvaise publicité à retirer chaque
minute c'est ahurissant des armées de
plusieurs dizaines de milliers d'humains
serait nécessaire pour faire un travail
comparable or il faut bien se rendre
compte que même si certains se targuer
d'avoir des algorithmes de détection
valide à 90% ce qui au passage est un
chiffre très bizarre notamment car il
suffit de créer soi même des contenus
problématiques facile à détecter pour
faire gonfler ce chiffre même les
algorithmes valable à 90% les serait
toujours passer une fraction non
négligeable de l'eau c'est en de
contenus problématiques ainsi 1 %
d'erreurs sur 100 millions de contenus
problématiques
ça représente toujours un million de
contenus problématiques accessible et
potentiellement massivement amplifié via
la publicité hashtag taxe sur la pub
2 on le sait bien il est bien plus
facile de rechuter dans des addictions
dangereuse si notre environnement
informationnel nous rappellent leur
existence et nous pousse à y succomber
pendant longtemps par exemple ce fut le
cas du tabac qui en plus d'être
dangereusement normalisée est même rendu
cool par la pop culture et le cinéma
était souvent promu dans des spots
publicitaires ou via le sponsoring
d'événements sportifs or on le sait
fumer tue mais donc puisque financer
produire et diffuser des publicités
pouce à la consommation de tabac cette
industrie de la publicité tue aussi en
fait il aura fallu des régulations
traces tic pour combattre ce qui est
rapidement devenu un problème de santé
publique majeur malheureusement ces
efforts n'ont pas été à la hauteur
jusque là pour d'autres substances
addictives comme l'alcool et le sucre
dont la consommation est également un
problème de santé publique majeur en
france l'alcool demeure la deuxième
cause de décès évitable après le tabac
tandis que l'industrie du sucre bien
connu pour sa désinformation
scientifique est une cause majeure de
l'obésité et de ses conséquences
sanitaires à l'échelle planétaire la
publicité pour ses produits semble dès
lors représenter un danger pour la santé
publique notamment quand elle cible des
jeunes enfants pour les attirer vers de
mauvaises habitudes alimentaires
hashtag texan la pub 3 beaucoup de
publicité s'appuie sur de la
culpabilisation pourra améliorer les
ventes de certains produits ou vendent
des rêve inatteignable qu'elle risque de
provoquer à terme des déceptions des
frustrations voir des ressentiments on
peut ainsi mentionner toutes les
publicités qui s'appuie sur des stars ou
des modèles de corps idéaux pour ensuite
vendre des shampoings des déodorants ou
des produits de beauté même si le
produit en lui-même n'est pas
nécessairement néfaste la publicité peu
habitué des milliards d'humains à se
comparer à ses modèles inatteignable et
provoquer des problèmes de santé mentale
comme par exemple liés au body shiming
dans le même ordre d'idées le cas des
adolescentes consommatrices d'instagram
est particulièrement documenté et
effrayant avec une augmentation
inquiétante du nombre de troubles
mentaux et de suicide faisant ainsi
probablement d'instagram d'après les
analyses des facebook files notamment le
réseau social le plus déprimant pour les
utilisateurs de façon plus générale de
nombreuses publicités un style dans la
culture populaire arrête de propriété et
de vie luxueuse souvent inatteignables
est difficilement compatible avec les
contraintes environnementales
hashtag tech sont la pub 4 les
écologistes sont à juste titre désespéré
par des problèmes comme l'obsolescence
programmée c'est à dire le fait que les
produits du capitalisme sont souvent
conçues pour devoir être régulièrement
renouvelés plutôt que pour durer des
décennies de manière fiable et autonome
cependant quand on regarde de plus près
dans beaucoup de cas le moteur de cette
obsolescence est davantage le désir des
consommateurs de renouveler leur
possession plutôt qu'un réel besoin de
renouvellement le cas le plus évident
est sans doute celui de la mode en
particulier celui des vêtements de luxe
cette industrie investit énormément dans
la publicité pour donner l'impression
qu'il est important pour eux de
renouveler chaque année leur style
vestimentaire
cette propagande fini par envahir
beaucoup de la culture populaire qui
normalise alors le shopping et
l'élégance de nouveaux produits or le
coût environnemental de cette industrie
est en fête et nord de la même manière
l'industrie des technologies s'appuie
vivement sur l' annonce régulière de
nouveaux produits et appelle les
enthousiastes à acheter la dernière
génération de smartphones dans ce cas
bien plus qu'une obsession ce programme
est dans la conception des produits ce
sont bien les investissements faramineux
dans la publicité qui rendent les
produits vendus pourtant récemment
obsolète ce qui pousse ainsi à la
surconsommation hashtag taxons la pub
enfin la publicité est un outil
fantastique pour normaliser et
déculpabiliser des milliards d'humains
de la consommation de produits
extrêmement polluant qui met aujourd'hui
des millions de vies en danger c'est
bien entendu largement le cas de
l'industrie automobile dont les budgets
publicitaires sont énormes non seulement
via la publicité audiovisuelle mais
aussi via le sponsoring d'événements
sportifs de la même manière les
publicités de viande cherche à
normaliser leur consommation voire à
susciter l'appétit des spectateurs et
surtout à négliger l'impact de cette
consommation non seulement sur
l'environnement mais aussi sur le
bien-être animal et sur la biosécurité
certaines publicités vont même jusqu'à
prétendre que la consommation de
produits animaux est une affaire
d'identité nationale alors qu'il ya
quelques siècles les steaks de grande
qualité était réservée à une toute
petite élite enfin la publicité
encourage le grand public à profiter de
vacances dans des destinations
lointaines eu égard au coût
environnemental des trajets en avion que
ceux ci nécessitent hashtag taxe sur la
pub
j'espère vous avoir convaincus que le
marché de la publicité est au moins
potentiellement problématique non
seulement pour la crise environnementale
mais aussi pour la sécurité des
consommateurs et même celle de nos
civilisations j'espère vous avoir ainsi
convaincu qu'un manque de contrôle sur
ce marché représente une menace
civilisationnel met donc à t-on un
minimum de contrôle sur le marché de la
publicité at ont accès à une vue
d'ensemble sur les dynamiques de ce
marché et en particulier sur la nature
des publicités et les plus courantes et
sur leur impact autant dans le cadre de
la publicité classique sur les affiches
à la radio ou sur les grandes chaînes de
télévision les relativement facile de
savoir quelle publicité ils sont
affichés et par exemple de vérifier que
les régulations existantes sous bien
appliqué comme l'interdiction de
publicité pour des produits illégaux ou
l'obligation d'accompagner toute
publicité sur l'alcool avec des
avertissements sur les dangers des abus
cependant de nos jours une énorme partie
de la publicité a désormais lieu en
ligne pour s'en rendre compte il suffit
de regarder la source de revenus
principale des géants de l'industrie des
technologies google et facebook ces
entreprises qui récoltent des centaines
de milliards de dollars chaque année
vivent quasiment exclusivement des
revenus de publicité ciblée en ligne à
chaque seconde elles reçoivent des
milliers de nouvelles publicités que des
publicitaires souhaiterait diffusé et
doivent déterminer quelles publicités
affichées à quel utilisateur et à quel
prix mais alors comment ces décisions
sont elles prises ces entreprises
tient-elle vraiment compte des
considérations éthiques comme l'impact
environnemental des produits promus et
leurs conséquences sur la sécurité et le
bien-être des consommateurs comme ces
entreprises le prétendent publiquement
ou ne fous tels que placer les
publicités des plus offrant y compris
quand ceux ci veulent diffuser des
incitations à succomber à des addictions
10 encouragement à profiter des
consommations polluantes voire la
désinformation ou du mépris pour
certaines populations pour le savoir en
plus de disposer d'outils algorithmique
extrêmement sophistiqués pour traiter
les milliers de nouvelles publicités
mises en ligne chaque minute un travail
clairement un faisable par une armée
d'humains seul et qui à l'instar de la
modération de contenus d'utilisateurs
provoquerait des traumatismes pour les
modérateurs pour espérer comprendre quoi
que ce soit ou marché de la publicité en
ligne actuelle faudrait aussi et surtout
avoir accès à des données à ce sujet or
suite au démantèlement de l'équipe des
tic chez google et la révélation des
facebook facebook google et facebook au
contraire renforcer l'opacité de leur
algorithme et de leur manière de traiter
l'énorme flux de données sur lequel
repose leur business y compris leurs
activités de publicité plus préoccupant
encore il aura fallu une enquête
judiciaire de plusieurs années pour
permettre à des procureurs de révéler un
accord illégale entre les deux géants de
la tech qui a eu deux disposent
désormais d'un quasi monopole sur le
marché de la publicité en ligne de même
il aura fallu fouiller et en 2022 une
investigation pour révéler le fait que
google annonce des prix différents aux
annonceurs et aux créateurs de contenu
en empochant discrètement la différence
au passage là encore l'opacité extrême
de l'entreprise rend le marché de la
publicité impossible à auditer pour les
clients les partenaires et même les
régulateurs force est de constater que
le contrôle que la justice et les
contre-pouvoirs on sur ceux qui
contrôlent le marché de la publicité est
extrêmement limitée et très certainement
que je pense très largement insuffisant
surtout sachant l'ampleur des
externalités négatives de publicité
google et facebook reste en très grande
partie des boîtes noires y compris aux
yeux de leurs propres employés surtout
lorsqu'il s'agit d'activités
particulièrement lucrative comme la
publicité en ligne la publicité en ligne
est littéralement hors de tout contrôle
et malheureusement les projets
extrêmement ambitieux de régulation à
l'échelle européenne comme les actes le
digital services act mêmes digital
market act des projets qui sont
extrêmement louable par ailleurs ces
projets me semble encore très largement
insuffisant pour corriger le fléau des
publicités ciblées incontrôlée qui à mes
yeux menace aujourd'hui la sécurité et
le bien-être de la population mondiale
même si n'étant pas avocat et n'ayant
pas lu ses actes en détail il y a très
clairement beaucoup de subtilité qui
m'échappe il me semble qu'une autre
législation redoutablement efficace et
urgemment requise de plus la législation
se doit d'être suffisamment consensuel
pour que son implémentation soit
envisageable est suffisamment simple
pour gérer les milliards de nouvelles
publicités en ligne créée par les
annonceurs chaque année c'est pour cela
que je trouve l'idée de la proposition 1
euros de publicité il ya dix euros de
taxe très séduisante mais bon entre nous
aussi beth des entreprises coupables de
complicité d'incitation à la haine à la
violence et même au génocide disons que
ce sera le cadet de mes soucis alors le
chiffre de 10 que j'ai donnée là et bien
entendu avant tout symbolique et pour
éviter un choc économique problématique
il sera en fait très certainement
préférable d'augmenter année après année
cette taxe sur la publicité pour
atteindre une attaque à sion de type
1000% bon encore une fois je suis pas du
tout attachés à 6 8% il a certainement
des façons beaucoup plus réfléchie
d'arriver à un taux d'imposition adéquat
pour la publicité et il tient justement
anatole qui s'intéresse beaucoup aux
changements climatiques et aux manière
d'atténuer ses conséquences désastreuses
un peu causer la question salut les
alors justement essayons de quantifier
quel niveau de taxes il faudrait pour
une entreprise qui dépense un euro dans
la pub d'un produit de néfaste une bonne
taxe ce serait quoi 50 centimes 2 euros
10 euros c'est pas évident de savoir
mais on peut faire un calcul d'ordre de
grandeur avec le rohan c'est le week-end
en appelle donc le retour sur
investissement d'une pub plus le rohan
est élevé plus les pubs sont efficaces
et en moyenne pour un euro dépensé dans
une pub une entreprise en récupère
environ 3 alors bien sûr ce chiffre
varie en fonction des secteurs mais en
tout cas il est supérieur à l'argent
dépensé donc c'est rentable et c'est
pour ça qu'on voit des pubs absolument
partout et ensuite si les pubs marche
les entreprises elles ont alors tout
frais qui s'ajoutent parce que plus
d'achats ça veut dire plus de
productions plus de livraisons plus de
personnel tout ça ça a un coût mais avec
un rouage de 3 c'est encore rentable
d'investir dans la pub et maintenant
avec la taxe sur les mauvais produits on
peut justement faire diminuer ce retour
sur investissement de certaines pubs si
l'euro as devient inférieur à 3 ce sera
presque pas rentable pour ses
entreprises d'investir dans le marketing
et si le roi devient inférieur à 1 là on
verrait quasiment plus aucune pub d'un
produit nocif donc on a déjà un premier
ordre de grandeur pour la taxe avec ce
raisonnement rapide ce serait un peu
plus de 2 euros de taxes pour un euro
depuis maintenant prenons un exemple
pour aller un tout petit peu plus loin
d'imaginer que vous cherchez à vendre je
sais pas des cigarettes il met vous
fumez monsieur si vous avez un tout
petit budget pub bien chaque euro
dépensé dans la com le sera de manière
très efficace vous lisez les études les
stats qui montre les socios catégorie
plus à même d'acheter vous regardez le
type de pub qui marche et vous aurez un
bon pourcentage de gens qui seront
intéressés mais maintenant si vous avez
un budget pub énorme bien vous pourrez
pas être aussi méticuleux stratégique
sur chaque euro vous allez dépenser
votre comme elle sera plus diluées vous
allez atteindre des gens qui s'en
foutent totalement le retour sur
investissement d'une pub il est donc des
croissants c'est à dire que plus on a
d'argent à dépenser plus on va en
récupérer en valeur absolue ça oui mais
en pourcentage de gens intéressés donc
d'acheteurs ça ça baisse en fonction du
budget l'euro at il évolué donc avec
cette forme là à peu près disons que
c'est le graphe nos fabricants de
voitures on voit qu'il dépense 50
millions par an en pub parce que s'ils
dépensent plus l'euro à ce serait
inférieur à 3 on applique à présent une
taxe de 10% par rohan investi résultats
la pente de la courbe elle est bien plus
grande et pour avoir un rouage de 3
l'entreprise est maintenant obligé de
dépenser plus de deux fois moins on
verrait beaucoup moins de pub voilà le
graphe pour une taxe de 50% de 200% une
taxe de 1000% l'entreprise dépenses
maintenant le qu'un million d'euros en
pub on enverrait quasiment plus aucune
parce que c'est 50 fois moins qu'au
départ sans la taxe avec ses graffs on
se rend compte qu'une proposition
intéressante ce serait déjà de commencer
avec une taxe 10% ce qui a déjà un gros
effet et de faire augmenter cette taxe
mois après mois pour arriver au résultat
souhaité un minimum de pub pour les
produits nocifs mais la grande question
se seraient alors comment définir les
bons produits c'est à dire les exemples
à suivre ceux qui seraient pas concernés
par cet axe et c'est super difficile de
donner un critère unique parce que comme
les biens expliqué un produit ça peut
être nocif pour plein de raisons pour
l'environnement la santé les addictions
etc mais pour chaque domaine on commence
à voir des critères qui essayent
d'agréger tout ça je pense par exemple
aux nues triste score dans les
supermarchés avec leur note de a à e on
pourrait dire que les pubs pour les
pires produits noté eux ils se prennent
la taxe plein pot les produits d un peu
moins et c'est jusqu'à a pas de taxe et
on pourrait mettre en place ce système
de notation dans chaque domaine donc
dénutris corps ok mais aussi des échos
score des addictions scores etc alors on
est un peu en train de fabriquer un
système de notation à la tournesol j'en
ai bien conscience mais bon c'est plutôt
bon signe il ya deux difficultés
principales pour arriver à ce résultat
déjà il faudrait d'énormes
investissements pour mettre en place les
labels et ensuite il faudrait les
appliquer sur toutes les plateformes on
voit de la pub notamment en ligne donc
c'est colossal mais ces investissements
ils sont absolument nécessaires
tout ça ça permettrait de définir un
cadre légal solide pour pouvoir ensuite
justifié les taxes c'est tout pour moi
ici et si la science autour du
changement climatique et des hautes
limites planétaires vous intéresse
n'hésitez pas à faire un tour sur ma
chaîne youtube ça s'appelle chez anatole
j'ai fait par exemple 3 résumé complet
des trois derniers rapports du giec en
10 à 15 minutes plein d'autres vidéos de
vulgarisation et merci beaucoup les pour
l'invitation hashtag taxe sur la pub
bien sûr la propose ht avec taxons la
pub est aussi un appel à la sobriété qui
peut paraître inquiétante pour la
croissance économique les dépenses des
saints sont les revenus des autres
clairement un chamboulement massive dans
les consommations d un aura des
répercussions économiques majeurs qui
menaceront certainement le travail de
certains autres il s'agit là en fait
plus globalement du défi délicat de la
transition vers des modes de vie plus
sains et plus durable ceci étant dit
selon la quasi-totalité des écologistes
une telle transition est non seulement
souhaitable elle semble aussi nécessaire
pour éviter une catastrophe non
seulement environnemental mais aussi
civilisationnel dès lors pour permettre
une transition si paisible et plaisante
que possible pour le plus grand nombre
plutôt que de seulement stoppé les
informations dangereuses comme les
appelle à la consommation il semble
critique également amplifié les messages
qu ils faciliteront cette transition
comme par exemple les encouragements à
adopter des transports durables comme la
marche le vélo ou les transports en
commun les invitations à s'essayer à une
alimentation quotidienne plus saine et
plus durable des explications sur
l'importance de l'isolation thermique
voir sur le port de plusieurs couches
vestimentaire en intérieur et oui c'est
possible et même utile de porter des
vêtements à l'intérieur quand il fait
froid et les appels à adopter des
habitudes préférable pour la santé
mentale notamment à ce titre les
publicités qui vont dans ce sens par
exemple en promouvant le cyclisme
l'isolation thermique les vêtements
chauds la compassion pour les voisins et
les thérapies cognitives
comportementales fois peut-être être des
publicités exemptés de taxes voilà qui
favoriserait aisément leur amplification
dans le marché de l'information et
permettrait ainsi d'avoir un marché des
publicités beaucoup plus sain pour les
consommateurs et la société de façon
plus générale au-delà du cas de la
publicité la guerre de l'information est
un enjeu critique enclenché la
transition écologique et surtout pour
faire en sorte que celle ci se déroule
autant que possible dans le respect
mutuel l'aide aux défavorisés le
consentement éclairé la bienveillance et
le bien-être pour vraiment y parvenir
l'échelle de toute une société il semble
urgent de programmer les algorithmes de
recommandations pour qu'ils amplifient
beaucoup plus massivement les contenus
informationnels de bien meilleure
qualité les explications des plusieurs
gens enjeux sociétaux et matériel
pédagogique pour une meilleure hygiène
mentale les contenus thérapeutique pour
la santé mentale les appelle à la
sobriété environnementales les
encouragements à des activités
écologiques et épanouissante entre
autres mais bien sûr il ne s'agit là que
de mon avis idéalement il faudrait ainsi
récolter les avis d'un grand nombre de
personnes pour identifier les contenus
informationnels jugé consensuellement
d'utilité publique et en particulier
pour déterminer collaborativement quelle
publicité devraient être exemptées de
taxes tel est justement l'objectif de la
plateforme tournesol à laquelle je vous
invite très vivement à contribuer notre
objectif c'est de disposer de
suffisamment de jugement de suffisamment
de contributeurs et on a besoin de
chacun d'entre vous nous seulement pour
mieux identifier les contenus a
recommandé massivement mais aussi pour
encourager la recherche académique à
s'intéresser à ce problème et également
pour influencer le débat public sur la
manière dont le marché de l'information
devrait être régulés en particulier si
vous semble que la proposition un lot de
pub il ya dix euros de taxes et
stimulante et suscite la réflexion je
vous invite à noter la vidéo que vous
êtes en train de voir en créant un
compte sur tournesol et en suivant le
lien en descriptions et bien entendu
n'oubliez pas d'utiliser massivement le
hashtag taxons la pub sur les réseaux
sociaux